[Music]
on this wednesday night a renewed
promise to help look for lost children
the federal funds to help find unmarked
graves of indigenous children who died
in residential schools
when children are treated this way it's
deeply deeply disturbing and
heartbreaking
while pressure mounts on the catholic
church to apologize
a reminder racism still exists
she would have had a better chance of
getting the care that she needed
if she had been in the street the
inquest into the death of joyce eshequan
in a quebec hospital comes to a close
what will it lead to the man who led
israel for 12 years is out of power
tonight
the unlikely coalition that unseated
benjamin netanyahu
plus an international cyber attack cuts
into operations
at a canadian meat packing plant and
wildlife tracking escaped elephants
on an epic trek
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
decades of political promises have been
made to indigenous people in this
country
most of them broken now news about
children buried in unmarked graves at a
former residential school in kamloops is
triggering new promises
the federal government says 27 million
dollars is available to help search for
other
lost children buried at former
residential schools
across the country it's not news that
thousands died in the schools indigenous
leaders and elders have known for
decades
and six years ago there was a detailed
report about missing children and
unmarked burials
what's been found in kamloops has
renewed calls to act
today the federal government said it
will assist but indigenous people
must lead the process
they have been very clear they want the
work to be indigenous-led
community-based survivor-centric and
culturally sensitive
they wanted support for the research
access to archaeological expertise
and commemoration it will
take time the work is as basic as
finding the graves
identifying the bodies and bringing the
children home from school
if that's what communities decide to do
david aiken has our top story tonight
alice victor ford resolution
baby red breast mona
these are but four of the 4 118 names
listed in the national student memorial
register the online registry of all
those indigenous children
known to have died at a residential
school there are
dozens of children on that list that
were not known by their full name
when they died when children are treated
this way
it's deeply deeply disturbing and
heartbreaking
this registry is the creation of the
national center for truth and
reconciliation
at the university of manitoba and the
registry was created with a one-time
grant
of 2.6 million dollars money that came
from a 34 million dollar
set aside by the trudeau government in
the 2019
budget to implement recommendations from
the truth and reconciliation commission
having to do with burial information and
missing children
now the federal government is ready to
dispense the rest of those funds
to indigenous communities more than 27
million dollars
to find unidentified burial sites
document
missing children and honor and
commemorate those children
let us people the indigenous people
take the lead in healing our own people
kuda enough is enough it has taken more
than two years to be able to hand out
the money
because of consultations and government
red tape the federal cabinet finally
signed off this week
on the plan to give the money to
indigenous communities and survivor
groups
150 years ago we were meant to be
extinct as indigenous people
150 years later we're still here and
we're in every facet of society in some
way not as much as we want to be
but we're here and that's to the credit
of the strength and the resilience of
our people
as for the speed at which the federal
funds will begin to show results
we are walking at the pace of
communities i know people are eager to
get answers as to what we will do
nationally and
what will the feds do the reality is
this is something that will be
dictated to us by the communities that
are affected
now there did seem to be an
acknowledgement today that if 27 million
dollars is not enough
ottawa will step up with more cash and
in fact it may not be enough
i spoke to an indigenous leader today
who told me that the cost of searching
for missing burial sites
can be as high as 50 000 dollars per two
square foot plot donna
david the catholic church ran many
though not all of the residential
schools
other faith leaders have apologized and
back in 2017 on a trip to the vatican
prime minister trudeau asked
pope francis to apologize it's one of
the calls to action
as well in the truth and reconciliation
commission report
six years later still no apology how
much is the pressure mounting
it is mounting and it's been there ever
since 2015 since the truth and
reconciliation commission but the church
has been resistant to
apologize but now you're right the
pressure has renewed in the last week
and now we have two of trudeau's cabinet
ministers asking the church to
reconsider
it's up to catholics across this country
to ask their church to do better
i think it is shameful that they haven't
done it
that it hasn't been done
now ultimately it's going to be up to
the canadian council of bishops
to think about making some kind of
recommendation to the vatican
donna all right david aiken in ottawa
thank you
money and gestures will mean little if
nothing is accomplished for indigenous
communities across canada and for the
tekkenlips to sequester
people the discovery of what are
believed to be unmarked graves isn't
only a reminder of the past it's a
reminder
indigenous children alive today still
face so many disadvantages
need through garcha reports from
kamloops
in downtown kamloops it's sadly not hard
to find someone who attended the nearby
residential school
below these symbols of support one
former student sitting on the street and
too triggered to speak on camera told
global news
reliving the beatings at the hands of
school administrators
has been nearly impossible to cope with
but he's encouraging fellow survivors to
seek counseling support
in hopes of true healing for future
generations
it's a cause sequence tribal chief wayne
christian has dedicated himself to
more children and care of the state now
than there ever was
when the indian residential school
system operated
yes it's a continuation people don't see
it that they don't see that connection
it's a multi-generational
legislative process and who pays the
price it's the kids
the children our children pay the price
he's calling for the abolishment of the
indian act and
systemic racism city officials are
responding
by giving those grieving some space i
think there's
obviously a great deal of healing that
has to happen within their own community
and i think we as outsiders need to be
patient and let that happen
as we wait for answers on next steps and
details about the discovery
any further use of ground penetrating
radar the most commonly used
technique in unmarked grave surveys may
require
national standards there's very clear
protocols that need to be used
so i think a national strategy is really
important here
to ensure that everyone who's doing this
type of work is following the same
general
procedures so that we can compare the
results and ensure we're providing the
best
possible information to communities
communities still
trying to come to grips with what's
happened think about a three four
five six year old think about that
what they did to our people our
ancestors our grandparents and our
parents
nitu garcia global news kamloops bc
hundreds of people marched through trois
riviere quebec today to honor joyce
eshequan
she's the atikumaku woman who died in
hospital last september after live
streaming video from her own phone of
the nurses insulting her
with racist taunts today the inquest
into her death wrapped up
as mike armstrong explains the coroner
is promising her death will not be in
vain
and a warning some of the video in his
story is disturbing
it was for joyce eschaquin's family four
weeks
of pain but they came to the inquiry
every day hearing from witness after
witness described the mother of seven's
final hours
how she felt how she was mistreated and
what went wrong
on the last day of the hearing a message
from the coroner
to eschaquin's husband i've always
wanted a pharmaceutical
she told him to teach his children that
a small revolution of reconciliation was
started
by their mother for the first time
outside the hearing room eshequan's
husband
did speak thanking the hundreds who
showed up in support
he says it's given him energy and
strength after a difficult inquiry
the family is very happy about that they
felt
all the warm that coming from everybody
but it was difficult
one of the first things the inquiry did
was watch the facebook live recording
a seven minute video where eshequan is
insulted by staff
and laughed at she was told she was
better off dead
and only good for sex
among the witnesses a nurse from the
juliet hospital
in the video she testified when she
heard it she couldn't believe it was her
called it cruel and begged eshequan's
family for forgiveness
now eshequan had gone to hospital with
stomach pains two days later she would
die of a buildup of fluid in her lungs
but according to an expert who testified
she didn't have to die
he said she would have lived if she'd
been monitored more closely
this is not just about firing one or two
people
the family's lawyer says a recognition
of systemic racism is needed
the inquiry is told that staff at the
hospital in 2018
was offered training on a ticamec
culture of 200 employees
only five signed up after eshequan's
death and the outcry that came with it
the regional health board made cultural
sensitivity training
mandatory mike armstrong global news
montreal
there is still so much learning to do
about indigenous people and the history
of how they've been treated in this
country
education is key six years ago the truth
and reconciliation commission clearly
laid out what has to change
it called for provinces and territories
to make age-appropriate curriculum on
residential schools
treaties and aboriginal peoples
historical and contemporary
contributions to canada
a mandatory education requirement for
kindergarten to grade 12 students
some governments have made significant
changes but alberta
ontario and new brunswick lag behind
heather urex west
explains
on monday students at this school on the
kikono metis settlement
in northeast alberta gathered together
to mourn
paying tribute to 215 children
buried near a kamloops residential
school we had
a service how we would traditionally do
and set up a memorial service if one of
our children died
is what i did with my students all
students here
learn about residential schools in all
grades though that's not part of
alberta's current curriculum
right now alberta students do not learn
about residential schools until
grade 10 and while a new curriculum is
being developed
many indigenous educators believe it too
falls short
the draft k-6 social studies curriculum
introduces 10 separate
references including a
proposed exercise for students to read
aloud from
the truth and reconciliation commission
but the proposed new curriculum
would not begin teaching kids about
residential schools until
grade five in ontario lessons don't
start until grade four
by the time kids are in grade five you
know they've already learned
a history of of canada that is based
in settler colonial views so now to
introduce the residential schools and
say okay
and here's another part of canada that
we didn't think was important enough for
to to explore with you because we didn't
think you're ready
i mean what kind of messages is that
sending for kids
it's why a growing number of critics are
calling for this
to change some educators are refusing to
teach it at all
it's a problem for me because i'm bound
by law
to teach from this curriculum but my
moral law will force me to look and
tweak and change and manipulate because
i know it's wrong
alberta's premier says the proposed
curriculum is
only draft and could still be changed
heather urex west global news calgary
there is breaking news out of israel
tonight opposition parties have reached
a coalition agreement that could oust
benjamin netanyahu the country's
longest-serving prime minister
moments before a midnight deadline a
coalition agreement was reached averting
for now a fifth consecutive election in
just over two years
the coalition is an unlikely alliance
between eight political parties with
ideologies that range from
the left to the far right and for the
first time a party of palestinians with
israeli citizenship
if it passes a vote of confidence likely
next week ultra nationalist naphtali
bennett would be israel's new prime
minister until 2023 and
centrist yair lapid would then take over
assuming the coalition holds
not going back to class coming up
ontario's decision
on returning to school
the third wave of the pandemic is not
easing up the pressure on manitoba
hospitals
intensive care units are still
struggling now in other provinces
offering to help the alberta government
says it will take up to 10 manitobans
who are critically ill with covet 19
they'll either go to edmonton or calgary
40 manitobans are now being cared for
out of the province
two are in saskatchewan and the rest are
in ontario
and some sad news today out of ontario
officials say
one person from manitoba who was
transferred there two weeks ago has died
he was a man in his thirties the ontario
government is facing a backlash over a
decision to keep schools closed
in-person learning until september with
case numbers dropping public health
experts had urged the province to
prioritize getting kids back into the
classroom for the last few weeks of this
year but
premier doug ford says the move is too
risky and says keeping schools closed
will help keep summer reopening plans on
track
i will not and i repeat i will not take
unnecessary risks
with our children right now the fact is
we're fighting a third wave driven by
variants
until we get more students and teachers
vaccinated
outdoor activities are safest right now
in a statement today the children's
health coalition which includes sick
kids hospital said it was deeply
disappointed
ontario has not acted on the broad
consensus for reopening schools and
said children must be a priority in the
pandemic recovery
there is a growing consensus the highly
contagious delta variant the one first
identified in india
is becoming a big problem for ontario
it's still unclear how
widely it's spreading whole genome
sequencing is needed to identify the
cases so
confirmation is slow though peel regions
top doctor says he's seen early data and
the trends
are concerning preliminary analysis from
the science table suggests that in one
month
the delta variant will be the dominant
strain in our region with the rest of
ontario weeks behind
dr lawrence lowe says discussions are
underway about possibly accelerating the
rollout of second doses in regions like
peel to get ahead
of the virus from gas to beef still
ahead how the latest cyber attack on a
private company impacts
canada
there has been another crippling cyber
attack on critical infrastructure in the
u.s
the target this time was jbs the world's
largest meat producer
it has plants in canada the us and
australia
as jackson proskow reports it appears
russian criminals
are the culprits more than a dozen meat
processing plants in the u.s and
canada are slowly coming back online
including this plant in brooks alberta
that supplies one quarter of canada's
beef
after a ransomware attack on jbs the
world's largest meat producer
brought production to a standstill this
attack
is a reminder about the importance to
private sector entities of hardening
their cyber security the attack is
believed to have been launched by a
group of russian hackers
similar to the one that caused the
shutdown of a major u.s pipeline
in that case colonial pipeline paid
nearly 5
million dollars in ransom while
americans paid the price
in major disruptions and gas shortages
russia
has basically figured out how to
commercialize cyber criminal activity
the u.s has faced the brunt of recent
russian cyber attacks
experts say the government of vladimir
putin is at the very least complicit
anything that happens on a given
country's territory that country
is allowing to continue we should view
as essentially state sanctions
in two weeks u.s president joe biden
will meet face to face with putin
in geneva armed with a long list of what
the u.s considers
malign activities it starts with the
aggressions in eastern ukraine
and the ongoing simmering conflict in
northern georgia
and extends also to the cyber realm
there's little sense
russia will relent this week the
country's foreign minister seemed to
stir the pot
suggesting the insurrectionists who
stormed the u.s capitol building in the
name of former president donald trump
are being unfairly persecuted we're not
taking any options off the table
in terms of how we may respond the biden
administration won't say how it might
address this latest hack
or russia's continued actions but stiff
sanctions remain in place
while the u.s urges private companies to
better prepare for future cyber breaches
jackson proskow global news washington
the journey's the thing not the
destination next the herd of elephants
wandering through southwestern china
[Music]
an environmental disaster is unfolding
off the coast of sri lanka a container
ship carrying tons of chemicals is sunk
after catching fire
it was carrying plastic pellets and
hazardous chemicals including nitric
acid the ship had been burning for
nearly two weeks
the coast is already polluted and
they're now concerned oil leaks
from the ship's fuel tanks could further
damage the coast experts warn this could
be sri lanka's worst environmental
disaster
a herd of 15 wild elephants has traveled
hundreds of kilometers through southwest
china
they have been on the move for months
now and have destroyed more than a
million dollars worth of crops along the
way
why they're walking is a bit of a
mystery as mike derlay explains there's
now an effort to try to alter
their course it's hard enough for a herd
of elephants to hide in the wild
in a city 15 elephants tend to stand out
this particular herd is all the rage in
china right now they left the reserve in
december
and are now just outside the provincial
capital of kunming
500 kilometers from their home a journey
that is now being documented and
scrutinized on local news
like a car chase
everybody wants to know why they're
moving north says this man
one local theory is that the herd's
leader is inexperienced and just got
lost
which ecologists say is unlikely
migration is a pretty
complicated phenomenon a more likely
explanation is environment
officials have said there isn't enough
edible vegetation on the reserve
and elephants eat a lot so far on their
journey they've consumed
56 hectares of crops it's easy to
imagine that you know
deteriorating conditions at home in the
reserve
might have triggered this movement out
to uh
use utilize areas that uh maybe a
century ago
would have been used by elephant herds
uh you know in the past
it's an issue china will have to address
but right now they need to keep the herd
away from the city of 7 million people
sirens didn't scare them off when the
police tried to block the road with
trucks
the herd found another path they're
elephants
they go where they want mike relay
global news toronto
and i feel like they should be able to
that is global national for this
wednesday i'm donna friesen tonight's
your canada is a spirit tree
in the bois de spree forest along the
seine river in winnipeg
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
[Music]
bye-bye